لكن ما نتوقع أن نسمعه في
الساعات القادمة من وزارة
الدفاع هنا في المملكة العربية السعودية هو
تفسيرهم لسبب قولهم إن إيران
كانت مسؤولة عن هذا الهجوم وما
يقولون إنهم سيفعلونه وسأقتبس
هنا بالضبط هم
يقولون إنهم سيقدمون أو يسمون
النتائج النهائية للتحقيق التي
تقدم أدلة مادية وهذه هي
كلمتهم دليل مادي على وجود
أسلحة إيرانية تثبت تورط النظام الإيراني ،
وهذا ما قالوا إن
العالم طلب دليلًا عليه.
سيحصلون عليه لاحقًا
اليوم المؤشرات التي نتوقعها إما
أدلة فوتوغرافية أو
أجزاء محتملة من الصواريخ نفسها ،
نتوقع منهم أن يشيروا إلى
لوحات الدوائر والمكونات الأخرى
التي استعادوها ويخبرونا لماذا
يعتقدون ما هي  يرون أن هناك في
تلك المكونات التي من شأنها أن تجعلهم
يعتقدون أن هذا كان إيراني
الصنع ،
والفهم الواسع هنا هو أنه لا
خطيئة  سيكون الفاعل غير الحكومي في هذه
المنطقة قادرًا على مثل هذا الهجوم
لأنه معقد لأنه
تم تنسيقه وتمكينه
بالإضافة إلى جرأته وكذلك
إغلاق نصف دبلوماسية إمدادات النفط في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
وهو شعار اليوم الذي
يبدو أنه  يتساءل السفير السعودي الذي يتحدث
في لندن أنه من المؤكد تقريبًا
أن الهجوم كان مدعومًا من إيران ،
لكن السعوديين لا يرغبون في الاندفاع إلى
صراع هنا ، هذا قال إن
المنطقة بها صراعات كافية بالفعل
وأعتقد أن هذه ستكون الرواية
الناشئة عن وزير الخارجية مايك
اجتماعات بومبيو إلى جانب
ولي العهد السعودي الأمير محمد بن سلمان
ووزارة الخارجية بالإضافة
إلى أن هناك جهدًا لبناء
دعم دولي واسع النطاق
للموقف السعودي الأمريكي القائل بأن إيران لها تأثير ضار
في المنطقة ويجب
كبحها إلى أي مدى.  دليل على أننا في الواقع
سنرى مدى إقناع هذا
ما سنكتشفه خلال هذا اليوم NIC
Robertson CNN Riyadh Sau  دي العربية